I still can't believe Hassan didn't just show the collar.
It's such an L to just not not just show the collar, man.
Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. Let me go find this Laura Loomer
tweet. Dude, how does how does any right-winger say this when
Christy Gnome exists?
How how do you say this when Christy when Christy Gnomes exists?
Okay. You literally have someone who is the the I the head of
the Department of Homeland Security shot their dog and missed
and had to shoot them again. They didn't have enough bullets
to execute their dog the first time. Jesus.
Let's go.
The Hassan Raiden clips are awesome.
Okay, these are so cool. Ethan drops some more stories about
Hassan. Points to Hassan. Okay.
Bro, you Hassan shot coloring that innocent dog for no reason
just cuz he wants to walk around. That's not a prop for your
stream background. That's a living being. You're a sick.
I do. People are just soing out about this in like the most ridiculous
way. Like without really knowing for sure. I don't know. I don't
I just don't like running with this until we have a good way
of knowing. What is this? Oh, curs dog store. Dude,
I I think I watched this episode. Cursome just shooting all the
I'm watching video part, you know, shooting some vlogs. Give
me a second.
>> Jesus Christ.
How's it going?
>> Yeah, pretty good, thanks, mate. How about yourself?
>> Uh, decent. It's decent.
>> Yep. your opinion
on the Hassan's dog
>> on the I think people are like
>> I feel like people are treating it like you know for
sure that he like tried to kill this he tried to not kill that
he tried to shock this dog or that he like had a shot color.
I so I now think there's probably a shot color on that dog. I
don't I haven't seen a convincing thing that has that like boxed
out look to it with the green light on it that isn't a shot color.
Have you seen something like that yet? I spent a little time
looking. Not a lot of time
>> I think just you know what I'm talking about, right?
Like not not that long either. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Not that long
either. What I've looked at it seems like it could be like a
GPS thing. Um I've seen one that like it looks as though it has
a box on the side and so maybe there's some kind of like transceiver.
But whether it's a shot collar or whether it's like a GPS thing,
I think we've got no reason to think it is a shot collar. Right.
If people if people are like dead convinced that this is absolutely
a shot caller, I don't think so. I think the best of evidence
maybe that people have for it is like the little Yelp.
>> But even that, I don't think that that's true either.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Have you seen you've seen a clip
of it like deep? So, I thought I thought it was it's a Google
Air Tag for sure, right? >> Against Israel and >> but
this clip right here is like a big deal as well. This clip right
here shows like the the color is like you see the green light,
right?
>> Do you see this one? >> Where's my green light?
Hold on. >> Uh with the green light
>> I see right now. Oh, >> this is it beeping. >> Oh,
did you not get this one? Yeah, this one is. Do you see that?
So, this is like something battery powered. That's right here.
>> And the only thing I've seen that like really does that
to me is showing that it is a like shot color. Very likely. I've
only really seen shot colors that do this. And this right here
to me is the GPS air tag likely.
Um, Ogre Boy, I see you're here. If you want to come and defend
Hassan, if you got a thought on this, you're in the in the,
you know, the habit of being the Hassan defense squad. >> Why Why
would a Why would a Why would a Why would a collar beep but a
GPS not beep if it's battery powered? I just I don't understand
why this >> The thing that made me lean away from >> Yeah,
sure. The thing that makes me lean away from GPS is
this little thing right here, which I've seen a couple of different
pictures. I think that's like an Air Tag carrying thing you put
on a collar. >> So, that's a little additional thing. You
think in the exact same spot next
>> I think so. So, hold on. I'll show you what I think
it is. So, that's what I think that is, but then there's the
box thing as well. So, I think that's what that is. See this?
That like the Air Tag goes inside of it. Air tag goes inside
of it right there. I think I think that's what that is. That's
what it looks like to me. >> Right. Wait, can you go back
onto it? Cuz it it looks like it's like a big a bit bulkier than
that. That looks If you look at what this looks like on that
Jack Russell, >> that's like a teeny little thing that
you kind of
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, I don't think that's the whole
thing. Sorry. I think I think that's on top of the shock collar.
So, I think there's the this is the shock element and this is
like another thing attached on the side.
So this this box right here, this black box,
that is the shot collar and this circular disc is something attached
to the collar that is like foreign air
I think uh we have one other clip of this. Let me find
Wait, but if you look at how it's positioned, right, you've got
the the square bit in the middle and then you've got the kind
of like rectangular bits on the side you're supposed to thread
through the collar. If that's what if that was actually threaded
through the collar, wouldn't that guy like get in between in
between the prongs? >> Get in between the prongs because
they're like right next to each other >> maybe. Hold on.
I think we got Let me see if we can find more of this. So, there's
apparently some good looks in this one. So, give me a second.
Yeah, they're right there. So, here's like this. There's clearly
this whole piece right here, which is the circular disc, which
I think is the Air Tag thing.
Mhm. >> And then there's this box which lights up green
at different times. Yeah. The I wish I wish anybody could ever
articulate to me what they think that that like color too tight
clip means. I just maybe you could argue it's like because it's
a shock color. I just I understand everybody mentions it. I don't
think it's like I don't think it's proof positive or dispositive
of any theory. It seems like a totally worthless clip to me.
I don't think it really supports anything. In my experience,
if you've got like a an older dog or if you've got a Jack Russell
or not a Jack Russell, like a St. Bernard, usually with like
looser neck skin, it's got to be a little bit tighter. Not that
it actually hurts the dog, just cuz it's like a lot easier to
like for the dog to like wiggle around it if it's got like a
ton of loose skin.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure. Yeah, I would agree >> It's
possible that, by the way, it's possible this is something else.
I think um there are like
uh electric fence collars that will like kind of give a either
a shock or like something. I I don't think Kai's getting like
hurt by this. Whenever a dog yelps from like a shock collar,
it's more from like a spook than a uh like pain really. Like
they're not I I don't think most of the time you set them up
to be like hurtful, at least modern ones. >> And Hassan's
had a lot of clips reacting to people suggesting shock collars
and he's been like no absolutely not ever for my dogs. So, this
could be like um I think there are some that are ultrasonic,
like some that get them like basically give them like a beep
and then I think there are some that would just vibrate as well.
Oh. Oh, I heard sorry I had somebody in my chat earlier talking
about something that was ultrasound. Uh and I thought they meant
they were um
like zapping the dog um with like high high beams. Um I realize
what that's talking about now, right? So, it's something that
the dog can hear but humans can't, right? >> Yeah. Just
in some frequency the dog can hear. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Look, I got I got Ogre boy here. You want me to drag
him in? >> I feel like Ogre boy is always He's always going
to have the the primary Listen, he's going to defend Hassan.
>> Ogre boy, what's up? How's it going? >> Okay,
so he gets this dog. He potty trains it on screen.
He laughs about the fact when she all over inside the little
fenced area that she has or he has for her, >> picks the
dog up and runs it outside
>> and it's like a joke. It's like a meme. >> He
sends the dog to a gillion dollar posh doggy academy for training.
He has all of these clips like you or at least the one clip that
you found that talks about how he would never want to do that.
And after all of this, he decides on stream, no less, >> that
that's when he's gonna say go against everything that has come
before >> and he's going to start zapping the dog like
in 4K
>> just in front of the world under all of these previous
events.
>> This was the argument that I was making as well. The
idea that as a streamer, you'd have like a dog that's like a
fixture of your stream, right? People in your chat know who it
is. it's like constantly in the background that you're going
to start like having a shock tolerance neck and zapping it while
you're live on screen so that it's going to what yelp will be
shocked for like tens of thousands of people to see live especially
when if you watch the clip I mean I just like sent it to you
the dog is already turning back and going back into its bed just
by a son like telling it off right >> oh and but there
are many many clips of him of Kaya coming down a little bit and
him going, "Hey," and she'll get back on the bed, right? So,
when he has the power to just go, "Hey,
>> I don't know why you what pushes you to get a shot caller
at that point to me is a little confusing." He's just like, "Yeah,
like, hey." And Ka goes back like there are I think we had a
clip or a video from today where he does this. Hold on. Give
me a second. Uh, not from today. Sorry, from yesterday. 1 hour
I think I remember the time stamp being. Give me a second. Goes
past broadcast. I'll just pull this up real quick because I I
do think this one from
>> You can see her jump down. >> Oh my god, I'm so
annoyed with everything. I'm running on >> criminals are
not exceeded. >> It's Oh, maybe
>> I I'll just find it real quick. It might be 112 >> for
most of this and then they can his
>> I mean just where you're
>> I guess go through and find the the thing as well especially
when the dog like steps back onto it >> it lurches to like
pull back its right paw which makes me think that's exactly what's
hurting in that in that moment and then also it's the fact of
it's literally passing just past like the bed post it seems like
the Jew claw possibly gets caught on it cuz it's like the inside
of the right leg, right?
>> Her son like turns his head around, like whips it around
as if he's like shocked that the dog might be hurt, asking what's
wrong with it. >> I don't know if he like
caught itself on the side of Well, he goes to look at the dog,
right? >> Uh I think he the dog >> at least seems
surprised at the fact that the dog is like yelled.
>> I think he Yeah, he goes to look. I don't know. I've
I kind of get what you're saying. I don't I don't think that's
like positive or dispositive in my opinion. >> Well, no.
It provides like an alternative explanation, right? That the
dog's just like cs itself on the side of the bed,
>> which I mean seem to be they look kind of like shiny.
Is it like a metal side to it or something like that? >> It's
got Yeah, it's got like a metal side metal sides and then some
little things in the corners.
>> So, it seems perfectly plausible the Dan has like or
the Dan's dog has just like clipped itself on the side. caught
it due claw, something like that. >> And there's other
there's other too when it boils down to it that like you don't
know what the else happened like earlier in the day. He might
already know that like she was favoring her paw or whatever or
there could be some aspect of like we're just not aware of. I
understand that like that's why people do clip chimping. I understand
the optics of it are something that you could slap a narrative
to it and run with it. But I'm saying because you here's my here's
a fair question because I haven't even watched the clip that
much. Can you see his hands prior to that?
Because one of the things that he's known for doing and there's
a clip where he's playing with a fidget toy to the point where
it breaks and jizzes in his face where he plays with like toys
and stuff or he's usually got something in his hands he's with.
I understand that there you made the point. I think one of the
times I tuned in earlier before I started streaming tonight,
you said that you can hear him drop something in his left hand.
>> It could have been that he was [__] with
it anyway.
>> He could have been like he thought that maybe he needed
to get up or whatever, so he ends up dropping this thing because
he doesn't need it anymore or whatever the case may be.
>> I think this is
hyper
pure, super pure agrade copium. Um,
I don't know. This I Listen, I'm with you. This This just sounds
like any way to try and recognize that Assan hasn't done this.
I don't think you need to go that far. There's like reason to
think that Assan hasn't shocked his dog, right? It's live on
stream. He hasn't had evidence of them doing this. He said before
he doesn't want to use shock collars. Um, and there's like an
alternative explanation like right there. Just as the dog yelps,
it pulls back its right hand. It seems to pass right over the
uh the bed's edge. Seems perfectly likely that he's like just
like clipped his juke claw and that's what's caused it to yell.
>> I don't think you have to reach into like you've got
no idea what the dog's like general health might be. Like it
might have arthritis. Sure, but we don't have to assume that.
>> Pulling it into the bed just as it kind of yelps. >> Read
Santa Kelly. >> Didn't shock his dog because doing so would
be stupid. In short, Destiny is innocent. Yeah, I'm not saying
it would be stupid. I've never used >> case close. >> I've
never used this like argument that oh, it wouldn't be smart to
do it. It's
like I don't know. I just Man, everything about how he like raised
his dog gave me the impression that he wouldn't have. >> But
I what I don't get is why he's got the collar with the big like
black box on it that most shock colors have. >> That That's
what I don't get. The black box that's got the batteries in it
like that's doing the green lighting up thing. That's what I
don't know is I I just want to know what kind of color that is.
And I think he easily could have answered that on stream and
made it make sense,
But he didn't do that. I don't know why he didn't do that if
it's like not a shot caller. >> Well, because also at the
same time like I I have a a Chihuahua and like a cat. I love
the cat. I'm very fond of the Chihuahua, but I love the cat.
If somebody sudden suddenly started telling me that I was abusing
my cat when I hadn't done a goddamn thing to it, I would be really
frustrated and pissed off. Especially when you have probably
a hundred rotating people coming in every 5 minutes asking you,
"Bro, why are you beating your dog?" Like, it would put me in
a mood to where I wasn't really thinking as clearly about trying
to immediately start defending myself like into that degree.
Like, yeah, it's but it's also going to be something that it's
not ever going to be good enough. You could say that no, it's
this brand of collar and then someone's going to turn around
and be like he just swapped it out uh so that
to throw off the the the trail because you know what I mean?
>> Yeah. Well, but that's why I thought he should have
just showed it like immediately. He should have just gone, "Oh,
this is insane." and pulled it off and shown it. >> I'm
surprised he didn't. >> I think a son's got like a a huge
ego and when he gets like an accusation like this, he just tries
to like take it like extremely non-seriously.
Um, Roger be engaging with it. >> Yeah, he does. He do
be doing that. >> I think he's just like a bit of a narcissistic
guy. >> Anyway, this is more time than I wanted to even
spend with this, but again, the I just think that the the the
time frame of like why the would he start doing that now and
so openly like that's just >> Hold on. Okay. I So, listen,
I can push from the other direction pretty easily. So, I'll do
that here. I the way I look at it is everything I've seen about
Hassan, he seems to care about this dog. He seems to actually
spend a decent amount of time making sure his dog's like well
taken care of um in a way that is different from how he treats
most other people and things. Okay. So I but I think he did describe
it. He's like, "Oh, dog's been hanging out with my mom. She's
like she's just been spoiled and she's not like actually maintaining
nobody's maintained discipline." If the dog was like doing this
in multiple instances, it might have been like, "Oh, I need to
retrain on a couple things.
I don't know. >> Okay. But he said, "So why not if if that
was an acceptable form of training in his opinion, why wouldn't
he been doing this since day one with like potty training and
why even bother? Like if you were going to go, I'm going to train
this dog by zapping the out of it and that was something that
was acceptable in your worldview, why would you have even bothered
to send it to the [__] academy thing or whatever?
Would you bother to send it? >> I think I I don't need
I don't think you even need to do like the speculative question
question, right? If you Wait, Jason, just play this clip,
>> but after he tells the uh after the dog starts walking
back, just play it in slow motion for me. Have you got the sound
on?
>> Uh I've got sound. Do you want me to just pull it out
of the VOD or
>> Yeah. Ah, yeah, that's better. That's better. Just to
like think through if this is true. What's the thought process
>> Reason first world, right? So, the dog steps out, >> but
it
is emblematic. >> Okay. You want me to drop it slow?
>> Um, I'll tell you to pause and then drop it in slow
motion if that's all right. >> Of all of America's much
more
It's the same reason as to why America
>> notices it, >> tells it off. He rolls rolls his
eyes back in his head. >> Immediately looks over at the
thing that he I think clearly picks up in his left hand here.
>> Yeah, possibly. Sure. But he sees the dog is like what?
Poison its head back. Stops walking back. >> Yeah. Well,
no, he doesn't see that. He's not looking at the monitor anymore.
He's looking down.
>> But he knows that
walking back, right? America.
>> This is where he's looking when he sees
>> So he's looking he's looking over to his right when
he sees Ka.
It's the same
reason as to why America.
>> So he's there. There now. He sees Kyle over at this
part of the monitor. And then when he goes to like when he gets
annoyed, he looks over to his left and down at like what you
would think whatever would be there. I don't know. >> Ka,
please just go.
>> So yeah, the dog's going back. I think if someone has
never used this before,
>> wouldn't you be watching while you're zapping? Especially
when especially when the dog has like always gone back when it's
told it off. The idea that he would
look away after shouting at it and then immediately start to
like zap it
>> wouldn't be around
no scope and doing like the no look zap. >> Okay, the no
look zap could make sense.
>> I Okay, hold on. The no look zap could make sense. The
issue to me is that he can obviously get the dog to go back on
the bed by just saying anything. by being like, "Kai, hey, hey."
>> And so to me, it's like, why do you need a shot collar?
Why would you even risk doing this somewhere around stream? Um,
when you just go, hey, the dog gets back
That's all. >> Mhm. But if you if you take it back like
5 seconds like before the dog yelps
>> and just focus on the dog rather than a
>> Sure. Go over to just Ka.
>> Okay. Well, >> reason as to why America Ka
>> ka please.
The the eye roll is so funny to me. >> So sad there. >> It
knows what's about to come. >> It's running back to its
bed to escape the 40 amps.
>> So we want to focus on >> we want to focus on
this left paw. We want to focus on the right paw here. Right.
That's what you think it's the
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> So, left up, left down, right
paw pulling into the bed.
>> I man I think I think he starts yelping before his his
paws even off the ground. >> Her paw's even off the ground
there.
More consequential
>> Okay. It's the same reason as to why America ka please.
>> Okay. I'm gonna I'm gonna be >> as soon as I can
>> as soon as I can.
>> you can see that is that the audio is slightly desyncted.
This is not cope. If you look at his mouth, if you look at his
mouth right now as he's speaking,
>> okay, yeah, it's a little possibly a little desync.
Which direction is it desc?
Because
right here she's like starting to pull it up >> and you
before it's even off the ground she's like yelping already. >> But
then I guess that would be >> the dog pulls the leg up
>> cuz Yeah. I'm guessing >> I guess my question
would be like where's the pain? That's not the dog just regular
like walking away. It stays in the same spot. >> It's not
carrying. >> It just pulls its leg up >> into its
chest instantly. Fine.
>> I think so. I thought maybe it had like caught its like
paw here on the other side. That's what I had thought
So yeah, I don't know. >> It's also hard with the audio
desync to know for sure. Now I need to now I need to download
this in 4K and un
and reync the audio. So it's like
>> I hate you so much right now. This is so weird. It's
like watching the ZRU film. >> This is I'm sorry. This
is like the most funny. You can see Kennedy. You can see Kennedy's
uh >> You can see Kennedy's head going back and to the
left. Back and to the left. >> Like the [__]
>> Also know that I did this for two hours at the beginning
of my stream.
>> I just think people have like watched this, heard a
dog yelp, seen that a son is reaching for something and actually
like looked at what the dog is doing. They don't want to watch
it again because it's like kind of unnerving to listen to a dog
like yelp, right? and they've just gone like emotional mode,
animal being hurt, >> and then also with the other stuff
of like what the dog has to sit there for like seven hours a
day. I mean, I said that when I first watched it. That seemed
insane that you're shouting at a dog for doing nothing and wondering
about, right? >> I also just said, everybody said that
they're like, "Oh, the dog sits there." I'm like, "Bro, show
me a stream where that dog just sits there for like 8 hours and
like looks like it wants to go outside or something." Cuz I feel
like probably what happens is the dog sits there for like two
and a half, three hours or something and then wants to go outside.
Han lets it out. Like I'm guessing that dog goes out almost on
average at least once per stream.
I'm just I'm guessing
that's what I said earlier. Like seven hours for a dog just like
sitting there, no food, no water, no wondering about. That seems
very very odd regularly every single day. I don't know.
>> Yeah. So, I think also I would agree with some people
like you do crate dogs, so not moving isn't that big a deal,
right? But when you crate dogs, I think you usually crate them
with water, if not food. Definitely water.
>> Yeah. Well, when you crate dogs, they'll lie down cuz
they can't go anywhere, right? They're in a crate. >> Yeah.
Yeah. So, like if you could train a dog and just tell it to sit,
like it's it's possible a dog would be like okay with this, right?
Like would be actually okay with um with just lying here.
Trading dogs for multiple hours is bad. Rawhead Rick, you are
a Nope. Creating dogs is totally acceptable. No, you guys don't
know about crate training dogs. That's fine.
>> Bye, Aiden. >> Wait, did you disconnect him?
>> Oh, okay. Okay. >> He just joined and then he
left. I don't know why. I don't know why he did that. He He'd
be doing like that sometimes.
So I would I would put money I would put hard cash on the fact
that Han is going to show this possibly in the next few days
and all the evidence we're get going to get from it is that Assan
did not shock this dog. I'm 90% sure
this dog hurt its Duke claw
innocently
>> Um it's possible. >> What are you What are you
putting it at? >> Oh I think I think I would bet on the
dog having hurt itself and him not doing the the shocking. I
would like bet on
honestly just mostly on like a human empathy level of like I
think Hassan like loves that dog and I think he's always loved
his dogs and I think basically nobody's ever questioned that
he loves his dogs
and I think he's shown like a lot of uh like actual distaste
for anything approaching like a shock collar in the past.
Yeah. Yeah, >> I think all all the evidence that this is
a shot collar is that it looks like it's got something on there
maybe and that son like moves his arm, >> but he's spoken
negative negatively about shot collars. Um
>> in the past he said that he won't use the one his dogs.
>> It seems like a small infraction. He doesn't like he
knows that it will go back to his bed if he just like shouts
at it.
>> Yeah, I think more than anything >> I don't think
personally there's like a reasonable basis on which to believe
>> that he's like shocked this dog. I think the the so
the the what do you call it the evidence in favor of it being
a shot color is the eyes like watching as he goes down to the
thing he puts the thing down that's clearly on that same side
and also the blinking light on the collar like the blinking light
on the collar to me is just like baffling
>> hold on it's not a shot collar
>> hold on hold on if it's not a shot collar but if it's
one of the other things that you were talking about what's your
thoughts on that >> uh if it's like a invisible fence collar
or a I I guess if it's a like ultra Sonic collar or something.
I wouldn't
>> Yeah, if it's I I don't think I really care. I think
>> I think he's like trying to train the dog. I don't think
it's bad for the dog to train on the to sit on the bed. But at
the same time, uh I also know that a lot of people don't understand
animals. Haven't had animals. Don't understand training animals.
Have never had like a working animal of any kind. Not that Kai
is a working animal. So they they have like this idea that like
you have to always always overcuddle dogs and cats like no matter
what. They have like this weird idea. It's like basically I think
there's a solid argument for like Elinity did nothing wrong and
she almost got run off the [__] internet when she
dropped that cat. So >> what about Lav when she was throwing
it? Haunts her to this day or does it? >> It doesn't. Yeah,
it doesn't. >> I've got somebody in my chat right now.
Um,
isn't there a clip of Assan saying he uses shot colors? No. There's
a clip of Assan saying his friend uses Shot Colors. He said he
bought one, but he said he'd never use it. Um, and has never
used it.
>> Yeah, there are a couple of those >> on the bed
gets twisted rolled ankle. >> I don't think there's any
pulls up the wrong wrong ankle if that's if that's the case.
>> What about when labs suck the dogs? Um, well, listen.
We're going to adopt the YMS standard there and say no harm was
done. Okay, just kidding. That was a female dog. That's a joke.
>> Jesus Christ.
What are you put What are you putting out at OG boy? You seem
pretty confident if you had to grow percentage either >> I
don't think it's a shot caller, especially for everything that
he had said prior.
I just don't. It's so stupid and especially for the number that
times that he's talked about it. And if it was something that
he was going to do, he would he would, like I said, I think he
would have been doing it from the jump.
>> But if you had to give a percentage on
>> like single digits, I think it's probably something
else. It's probably like the sonic color or whatever.
Okay, hold on. I need to show just somebody in the chat is not
uh did was unaware that it's a like battery powered
>> So, if you watch this clip, okay, you watch that. What
just went by there? You'll see this green light turn on. >> So,
all that >> it's a little blinking light. Okay, see green
on off on on off on. >> But all that indicates is that
it's something battery powered and that it has power, right?
>> Yes. Well, it's like letting you know it's on. >> Could
be ultrasonic.
It could even be a shot collar. Um, but
the evidence to say that is like scant. It could be other stuff
as well. Just said he doesn't want to use shot
>> I would say this is another another question is why
is it if it's so big and obvious, why would he even put it on
her when she's like on stream? Like why would he risk that if
uh it's that big and obvious? True.
>> I mean that's
off stream.
>> Give me a second. Somebody else is saying this is a
clip clip with evidence here. Hold on. >> You have to be
so darn sure that you're >> watching some dog training.
>> Dog is not going to hurt another dog. >> Also,
if you have chatter said he has a problem with barking, if you
I mean, you might need to get a bark collar potentially. Some
people say it's inhumane.
Um, not all bark collars actually shock uh dogs for the record.
There are non-shocking bark collars, too, for the record. So,
just calm down.
Sometimes it just makes like
a noise. Oh, >> like an ultrasound collar. Is that what
he's talking about? >> I think that's what he's talking
about. >> Some bark collars just vibrate. Some make high-pitch
noises. Not all of them are electrocuting ones. Bark collars
are never okay. No. Just no. Never okay. Okay. Well,
never okay. At a bare minimum,
>> that's still not the best look, but at a bare minimum,
that would at least say that like even if he went that route,
that it's not a shock collar in the sense that he's electrocuting
his dog. >> But this this doesn't weigh on the the example
we're talking about anyway, right? The dog didn't bark. So,
>> even if you want to say that it is like a even if you
want to say is a B color. >> We're we're clipping that.
We're clipping that. I heard it. I think other people heard it,
too. We all We all heard that voice. >> I don't know what
you're talking about. >> Yeah, we all heard it. Clip that.
Clip this man. Clip him now. >> He's just British. They
sound like that. >> okay, I know that Estan is here talking
about like the openness to a B collar. He says he don't have
to have one that shocks. So, is he open to it? Is it not? I don't
know. I think it's a wash. But even if you do think this has
played into like how he's treated Ka. She didn't bark. She yelled.
And that was the that was the indication she was in pain. Right.
I thought >> No, not necessarily. Dogs Dogs do yelp when
they get scared. >> I don't know if you've never had a
dog like this. Dogs absolutely yelp when they get scared. Like
if they're caught off guard by a touch, if they're not expecting,
like even something that touches them when they're not expecting
it, like in a soft way, they will freak the [__]
out and yelp.
>> I've seen that.
>> Yeah, but I thought I thought the whole idea with the
clip is Okay, I might be wrong. Aren't people believing that
it's yelping? Therefore, that's it when it's in pain and then
that's that's the >> People are sure,
>> right? Well, to to believe that, it'd have to be like
what? The the dog got the got the dog got zapped when it yelped,
but it didn't do anything. It didn't make any extra sound when
it was zapped. In which case, like what is the evidence that
there was a shock there? >> Oh, you're saying Okay. Okay.
So, you're saying the it would be like a a bark activated collar,
per se. Like that's the that's the point you're making to say
that that's not what it is,
right? Is that what you're trying to >> I don't know. Is
that what you're trying to say, Deckers? >> Well, I I'm
just saying. Okay. The only evidence that this dog was like her
was the Yelp. So, if we are going to use this clip to assinuate
that it's like a bark zap collar, you could say that any time
that a dog is like barked,
right? If the noise that the dog made is the evidence that it's
like some kind of like shot collar,
if you want to say there's a bark collar, that doesn't play into
it at all. Right. >> No, no, no. I think I think what the
suggestion is is it's still still probably some sort of disciplinary
thing, but that it's it's um not a electrical one. Wait, if you're
trying to do you think he was disciplining Kaia there with like
some
remote or
>> I No, I still don't think he I still don't think he
was, but I'm saying that in even then I think there's enough
there to show that it wouldn't ever be something that's electrical.
Does that make sense?
>> Okay. Yeah, I mean that does make sense. And then I
I think could be disciplinary. It could be um like one of those
what do you call it? Invisible fence collars too. Like I don't
know what the outside of his house looks like, but maybe they
try to keep her in like a specific area or maybe there's like
possible gaps in the fence that they don't want her to sneak
out through. Not totally sure
>> or right.
No, because the idea the Braden memes and the whole idea is that
he's electrocuting his dog. And I think that
>> the idea is to show that he's still against that aspect
of it and that if he was going to do something that was disciplinary,
he would find something >> Or is the idea that you're presenting
here Jaw because there's like other stuff that the color could
be
if not like a remote controlled shot
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I just I I don't know what kind of
color it is. I do wish that he before he had walked away >> shown
the stream what kind of color they just pulled it off and shown
them right then that it was like whatever kind of color cuz I
think I think now nobody's going to believe him in any possible
case. If anybody would have believed him before there would have
been some people right and yeah the internet the internet's like
entering what do you guys think of the fact that the internet's
entering a place where it's like I feel like people are shifting
from like I don't know
Whatever the ratio of like criticism to actual content generation
is, it's going to like all criticism now
is very interesting. The internet like >> it's going to
boil so this is going to boil down to if you have any charitability
for him at all, you're going to give benefit of the doubt. But
if you if he's been someone that's been on your radar that you
hated, suddenly you've been working for the ASPCA for like seven
years and you're not going to tolerate this Houthy terrorist
loving piece of [__] beating his dog around the clock.
Like that's that's what the narrative is. I'm sure Kyla already
has a tweet up where she's like, "This is not something I'm gonna
tolerate or stand because like that's the line that you have
to carry." >> Snarking on Kyla right now. I saw you in
her chat the other day.
>> I on a whim. I looked at what the was going on and she
had Gandalf the wizard sitting next to her. I was like, "What
the is this shit?" Uh >> oh. Wait. Ogre boy, do you not
like Do you not like Ardite? What? You watch You watch her content.
You don't.
>> No, no, no. Watch is a bit of a >> Look, I tweet
about it. >> I'm old as and I channel surf and I even people
that I don't like or I still want to listen to like how they
phrase things and how they frame up certain and she was somebody
that hadn't streamed in like forever. So when I do go, "Oh, that's
someone that's on right now." I'll go like, "Well, let me hear
her talk about something so I can hear what the she's about."
And when I put on out of curiosity
some and it's not even a good wizard beard and I'm like what
the am I looking at and they're like oh we're playing uh what
the did the person say in return the the the Marvel game and
I'm like oh okay cool I didn't know that uh Teimu Gandalf was
a DLC character but yeah whatever
>> we've uh we've got the aerodyite >> of course
she [__] did >> it already got 100,000 views
before you even can conceived of it. Okay, it's already got 100K.
Damn, dude. You have no idea how easy it is, dude. Anti-hange
is so easy to get likes with. It's so easy. Every time is doing
the exact same thing right now that I think I've seen quite a
few other people do. People already seem to be like ditching
the unsteady ground of the shot collar narrative and it's going
on to like other stuff. Well, even if it's not shot collar, why
is she there for like seven hours a day? I don't know. Why didn't
you [__] mention it before? >> I don't I'm
not I'm not I'm not [__] on you >> that a son
like you know loves hates his dogs or abuses his dogs >> like
I'm not trying to [__] on you but like I don't I
don't Okay, I don't want This isn't a plug by the way. I don't
give a if I if I streamed for the rest of my life to five people,
but like I don't watch him that much anymore because I'm not
I'm trying to like not go live and just go here's what Hassan
said today or I don't want to just echo the things that I've
heard him say. I might have him on for like a half hour here
or there, but I don't even watch him that much anymore. The last
thing I think I ever want to do is to go here's what I'm going
to do today because I'm going to vindicate my hero and I want
to go jog dial and put a clip compilation together of all the
times she got up like in the last week so I can prove his haters
wrong or some [__] The his fans aren't actually that
insane. Maybe somebody might now that I've wished it into existence,
but like that's the only way to counter some of this [__]
And even then, there's still gonna just be some new goalpost
that gets shifted. It's like these people are twisted.
>> I don't know. >> That sounded a little hot, didn't
it? That was that was a little accurate. I >> I bet somebody's
going to do it at some >> I just I thought it was funny
that uh Missy Elliot's response to that was, "That's because
you're weak." Like, is it if you you would you would c you for
Hassan hard if you had the strength to. You've given up. >> You've
given up on Hassan.
>> Clearly. Anyway, I have a job I have to get up for in
the morning that I hate. So, you kids have fun. >> Okay.
See you later. Thanks for coming on. Bye.
>> Hey, this is this is what I'm talking about. The right
is is exactly what I've seen people do. Ethan is already pivoted
from like Hassan is abusing his dogs then on to like Hassan and
his fans. Crucial phrasing by the way. Crucial phrasing. Hassan
and his fans said that I was abusing my dogs/children.
Hassan and his fans supported the CPS narrative. It's like, okay,
so we've already pivoted pivoted away from the like shot collar.
Eight hours. We've gone eight hours and now we're talking about
other stuff. Why is she even there? Why is she even there for
eight hours? Why does someone do this?
I feel like people are only saying this cuz they know they're
on like Tety ground or the with the shot collar thing. They want
to solidify it with something like they can actually like prove
or actually talk about
>> the
forges. So, I don't know if you saw the Techone tweet, the Fslur
tweet that he threw out. >> Not just because it's a Techone
tweet, but he actually used the Fslur. Um,
where is it? Here. It's uh
Let's keep looking. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. This one. Disgusting.
Whoa.
Using your dog as a prop, shocking him to stay in place. I said
right away, I'm like, "Oh, that Dumbo imagery that like Hassan's
the carnival guy like beating Dumbo into like staying uh compliant
and entertaining for people." That's that's the worst imagery.
I thought that's what people are going to run with is just specifically
that idea that he's going to like torture Kai into staying there
on stream, >> right? I think I think that's what people
run with. And yeah, I I agree with you that Arerodite's probably
going to do that same thing.
>> I [__] I hate Techone so much. I uh whenever
Teone isn't like injected into any conversation ever, I just
I can't I can't I can't deal with it, man. I I do not want to
hear Teone talk about how another man treats his B. Okay, it's
not not from him. Not from him, from anyone >> Um he also
just doesn't understand dogs and it's very obvious he doesn't
understand dogs. My dog's been professionally trained. A shot
collar should feel like a gentle to firm touch, not as sitting
so high that it screams. Bro, that dog's hide is so insanely
thick. I guarantee you no shock collar you could buy on the market
standard would actually hurt that that dog enough that it would
scream. It's the shock
uh what do you call it? It's the shock metaphorically. Okay.
The the shock is into the system is in the unexpected nature
of the sensation that causes the >> Yes. It's not it's
not the pain. >> Anybody who thinks it's the pain is just
a [__] Yeah. And he's he's already talked about how
he would never want
>> Or like a small dog with like super thin fur, right?
If you imagine like a >> Like a chihuahua, like a bulling
chihuahua, I can imagine that like hurting that like stinging.
But I guess you probably wouldn't use a shot collar for that
>> or you'd use like a smaller one with
>> absent or something. >> I've had dogs before.
They've been like relatively like well behaved. I feel like if
you like raise your voice at it or, you know, start like looking
at it and, you know, like wagging your finger, they're usually
well behaved. Although I've only had like like or like poodle
breeds, so maybe my dogs are totally
um I've never had I've never known anybody to use a shot collar.
I don't really know if you can buy them in the UK. They might
be illegal.
>> Oh, I see. I have never heard of them. They're not illegal.
People use them. It's just like there are just way better ways
to train your dog. Like I think a lot of positive reinforcement
training is despite how stupid it seems sometimes and it seems
stupid sometimes. Most positive reinforcement training I've seen
people use is actually really solid and actually achieves whatever
you're looking for way more.
Um >> so yeah, I just think I shot colors are probably
like the least efficient way, one of the least efficient ways
to do training. I I I feel like these specialist type of collars
to like like freak the dog out. I feel like it's just ways for
people to if it's it's listen if it's a particularly like unruly
dog like in a pound or something it's been abused. Maybe I can
get it to try and get it like like normalized into society. I
think that if you if you bought a dog from a puppy, you're raising
it and you happen to like buy a shot collar. You're just you
you want to hit it. You like want you want to hit that dog, but
you don't want the guilt that comes with it. And so you buy like
a a mini portraiture device. I don't know.
I don't know. In my experience, it's just like it's not necessary,
is it? You don't need to do that. Just like tell it off. >> Just
like train it properly in my opinion. I don't know. >> Yeah.
I' I've seen some like goofy >> ways of training dogs.
Yeah, clickers. Clickers are good. Um clickers are good for training
dogs in the positive reinforcement way. I just love that Teone
actually didn't do what I thought Teto was moving away towards
just the dogs generally abused, but he's like, "No, no, no. It's
actually got a shot collar on a setting so high that the dog
screams when he uses it.
>> He's so performative and gross. I I [__]
hate this guy." >> Now that's what I call a hot dog. Okay.
Um,
on that dude, on that note, I'll uh listen, I'll chat to you
later, mate. We'll see how this transpires. We'll reconvene at
a later date. Um, yeah, I was expecting more of a fight from
you. I thought that you'd said that it was um you were 75% that
it was a shot caller.
>> I I said if I was going to bet, that's probably the
odds I'd bet on is like 75% chance it's a shot caller. Or like
if it's not a shot call, it's some kind of like negative reinforcement
caller. Um, I wasn't even saying I would bet that he was using
it there. I just think um Well, maybe I would bet that he was
using it there. I kind of think he was I I feel like that's a
more likely explanation given what I've seen.
I think man in my head I'm sitting here like uh but it's it's
pretty close either way. I just don't have like I feel like it's
not super strong either way. Erdite responded to Tony. Damn.
Hold on. I need to actually watch the clip because I've watched
it already but I need to rewatch it. You want to stick around?
Dickers is fine. But otherwise, thanks for coming on. Thanks
for >> Yeah. I'll chat to you guys later. Lots of blow.
Bye. See you.
The [__] did I put this airite tweet? Where' I put
this tweet? Where is it? There it is. Nope. Nope. Nope. Right
Here's the tweet to the news coverage for now. As I was saying,
um, while I'm waiting for Oh god. I'm going to actually let Kai
out cuz I can't stand her uh being in the background and like
and wanting attention as well. Okay. Okay. Up. Get out of here.
Go.
Go. Go. I thought Hold on. We had this before. Is this This isn't
this VOD, is it?
Oh, was this No, no, no. Where's the other VOD?
The Yesterday VOD. Hold on. Is this the one we watched? Cuz I
could have sworn it was not that bad when I watched it. Let me
see. Is that this outfit?
>> An increasingly smaller audience. Yeah, that is >> Well,
not actually fix Well. >> Okay. Okay. You didn't download
the app. It doesn't matter. Even if you download the app, it
doesn't matter. It just like automatically lowers my mic. Anyway,
all right. Let's get back to the news coverage for now. As I
was saying, um, while I'm waiting for Oh god, I'm going to actually
let Kai out cuz I can't stand her being in the background and
like and wanting attention to >> Hold on. Did I can't tell
if Ka did something here.
>> I could have sworn there was something that happened
before this when we watched it, but maybe not. >> Want
stuff like this. Make
>> hold on. Let's see. Let's see if she moves around here
at all. I guess they >> we have to officer of the courtying
violent ordinal
a little bit of confidence that maybe you know this is like basically
the last line of defense now >> I don't you guys are jib
I think you're on the wrong side of this but it's fine I don't
think he's just molding at the dog for existing >> of course
you shouldn't >> I'm trying to see what he's reacting to
sit around otherwise he's saying you should go out right now
>> go damn okay I'm going to
matter But I don't see anything here. >> Damn. Okay. Well,
I could have sworn I watched that one. There's like another timestamp
that I'm missing. I think there's something else that happened
there. We watched it earlier in the stream, but I lost it.
So, hold on a second. We got this one. Let me look at this teeny
tiny toy tweet real quick. What did I respond to? This one right
here. We get it. You want to be the dog sitting on camera getting
electrocuted and humiliated all day.
Did she actually Did she actually respond to this in some way?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I don't see a response.
This what? Hold on. Why doesn't this reply show up for me? This
is so weird.
This reply like literally doesn't show up for me for some reason.
Gone thought. Classic leftist misogyny. That's funny.
She kind of she's kind of not wrong here. Okay, she's kind of
not wrong. I'm just telling you she's kind of not wrong on that
one. Okay, Teeny Teeny Tiny Tony is a misogynist. It's just true.
Okay, I actually don't know that. That's a joke. That's I don't
know anything about Teeny Tiny Tony. I don't know.
Seems like a good guy whenever I've like talked with him about
anything. So So are you a little bit
spent too much time with morale? Maybe.
All right, I think yeah, that's probably it for us, guys. Thanks
for come or thanks for being here tonight. I am going to see
who we got online
on kick.
Uh let's see. What are we doing? Raid Fandy. Did they make it
yet? Or is Fandy just still grunting into a camera? Is that Is
that what's happening? Is Fandy still just grunting into a camera
for